[Music]
brother
good
[Music]
funny
so
good eat
hello welcome to the table my name is
karen miner i am so happy you're here
tonight whether you were here in this
room or watching online
so so glad you're here it is still hot
outside
it is still summer
hopefully it feels a little bit cooler
in here
i just have one announcement tonight and
it is our welcome to the table class
it is happening
the last sunday of this month august
28th immediately after the service the
welcome to the table class is a great
way to find out more about the table to
meet our pastor brett and hear more
about our story our mission our values
and also learn more about you and it's
also our membership class so if you're
interested in being a member at the
table which everyone is
is able to do and allowed to do here
then we would love to have you there if
you would like to register all you have
to do is if you're in this room you can
grab one of our cards it's right out
this back door and the little itty bitty
tiny table
there are cards there that say the table
put your name a way to get in contact
with you and you can just put wtt for
welcome to the table
if you are online you can either message
us through facebook
you can leave a comment on the live feed
and we'll make sure to get in touch with
you and give you information on that
which speaking of online
i've talked to quite a few people lately
who have watched online before visiting
here
at the church and that makes my heart so
happy because i know it is not easy
visiting churches for the first time and
especially if you've been hurt by the
church in the past which unfortunately
has happened and so i am so thankful for
our tech team i'm thankful to james who
is our online
uh uh
host for our our live feed and
it's just good to keep in mind that the
table is not just here it's also online
and you are all a part of that and
you're all welcome so how about if we
pray center ourselves before we dive
into worship tonight
and let's start by really arriving here
just take a nice deep breath in
[Music]
and out
one more time in
out
and then remember
why you're here why did you choose to
be here tonight to join online tonight
god thank you for tonight thank you for
this place and this space and these
people
thank you jesus that you are our center
you are a firm foundation no matter what
has happened to this week
no matter what's ahead of us
you are very near and always present
so god help us to tune into that tonight
help us tune in to you
to quiet our minds
and be receptive god to whatever you
have for us tonight
i pray that everyone would feel welcome
and at home here
and that there would be something
tonight god that feels just specifically
for each one of us
directly from you god
help us to trust you at deeper levels
help us to really really
know your love in a personal way
and to operate from a place of already
being loved not having to work for that
or strive for that
so god we thank you for that kind of
love that you offer us help us to
receive that for ourselves and then let
it flow through us to those around us
we thank you for that in jesus name amen
amen
thanks karen
um like she said welcome you guys if
y'all want to stand with us we're going
to
get started
with some worship tonight
i see a couple people's faces who are
new so for those of you who haven't met
everyone this is josh and joe brock up
here at the front
this is carter
yeah fan clubs i love this
this is my twin sister maggie so if you
feel like you're sick
[Applause]
and my name is mindy and we're just
really glad to worship with you tonight
we should do this every week i feel so
good
we should start like this every time
all right
josh is going to kick us off on this
first song so you guys sing out and clap
your hands if you would like to i
actually wanted to tell a very quick
story um earlier this week you didn't
have to stop i'm sorry i just remembered
earlier this week me and maggie and uh
our friend kelly who is back there
serving our little babies in the nursery
thank you kelly um did a dance workout
together
y'all it is as bad as you're imagining
it in your head right now
we did not look cool or coordinated it
was hilarious and later we were like we
should have invited karen
our resident dance mom she could have
like whipped us in shape
but because there's some kind of
study recently that i think brett was
sharing with maggie about dance and what
it does for your brain and your body and
your soul like your spirit just like the
connectivity
that goes on there and when we're in
worship together i know it's easy so
easy sometimes for us to kind of
disengage from our whole self and just
think of it more as like a mental
experience or
maybe you're singing out and there's
that part of your body that you're using
but everything from the neck down is
kind of uninvolved
but the more that we can be a holistic
person engaging in this with all of our
senses so movement you know is included
in that anytime we can do that i just
feel like we're experiencing more of the
character and the nature and the
creativity that god created us with
as whole people so nikki's back there in
the back and i know that she's going to
be joining in so if you want to join her
in the back
but for real though please clap move
don't feel like you have to be a
stationary robot that just moves your
mouth um we're in this together and if
you look stupid i can show you a video
later of us doing our dance workout and
you'll be like never mind i was rocking
it i was awesome so
okay josh now you can start
[Music]
when darkness tries to roll over my
bones
sorrow comes to steal the joy i
hold
[Music]
the brokenness
my fear doesn't stand a chance when i
stand in your love and my fear doesn't
stand a chance when i stand baby your
love and my fear doesn't stand a chance
when i stand
[Music]
alone
doesn't stand a chance
[Music]
there's power that can break up every
chain
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is my fear doesn't stand a chance when i
stand in your love and my fear doesn't
stand a chance when i stand in your love
and my fear
[Music]
doesn't stand a chance
all right
[Music]
thank you guys you kiddos can be
dismissed to your kids ministry classes
now
and we're going to keep rolling
[Music]
worthy of every song we could ever sing
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every
[Music]
jesus the name above every other name
jesus the only one who could ever save
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for you
we live for you
[Music]
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in wonder and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those around
me
[Music]
worthy of every song we could ever see
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever be
we live for you
[Music]
jesus the name above every other name
jesus the only one who could ever say
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
there is no one like you
there is none beside you open up my eyes
in
wonder and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those
around me and holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you open up my eyes
in
wonder and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those
around me
[Music]
i will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
i will put my trust in you
alone
and i will not be
shaken
i will build my life
upon your love it is a fur
foundation
i will put my trust
in you
alone
and i will not be
shaken
i
will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
[Music]
and i will not be shaken
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in one
show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those
around me
[Music]
as we move into the prayers of the
people you guys feel welcomed and please
read this along with us
and together we want to be a support
system that is shouldering each other's
burdens that is carrying the weight
of what we bring into this space
together and believing that god is also
sharing in that weight with us that he
is hearing us
so um if you're online please leave your
comments and we will share those with
the room as well
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick oh sorry for
those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed
the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
from on-line
from online please pray god's protection
on our students and teachers
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
so i was practicing the song that we're
about to sing
at my house today and uh there's a lot
that has gone on in my life in the last
long time it seems like
um
but one thing that is really i've really
been struggling with is
connecting to christianity
because i grew up in the church and
you know for lack of a better word it
was it was just thrown in my face all
the time and
and lately i've seen a lot of hate
in that realm
which kills me because i
am a lover not a fighter right
um and so i was singing this song and
this is one of my favorite songs
because i think it's a very powerful
song
and especially on the bridge um
there's a part that says seeing
hallelujah christ has risen
and it was i couldn't sing it
it was hard for me to say christ has
risen
um
because i didn't connect to it and then
i started thinking about well
you know
what what was risen in christ
and it was love
and
nikki you're gonna make me cry
um
and uh with the first time i sang it i
couldn't even finish it
because
if you go back and you change
uh tries to love in any scenario
man there's so much power in that
because christ is something we read
about right we hear about him as person
but love is something we feel
um and if god is love i have to imagine
that christ was loving as well
love was written risen on that day as
well too
so when you sing this with us and we get
to that part uh
we're going to sing love is risen
and
yeah i i hope it means as much to you as
it did for me it was very powerful
[Music]
are you hurting broken within
overwhelmed by the weight of your sin
jesus is calling
[Music]
have you come to the end of yourself
to your thirst for a drink
[Music]
the precious blood of jesus christ
leave behind your regrets and mistakes
come today there's no reason to wait
jesus is calling
bring your sorrows and trade them for
joy
from the ashes a new life is born
jesus is calling
[Music]
was
the precious blood of jesus christ
[Music]
the precious blood of jesus
and so what a savior
isn't he wonderful
sing hallelujah
is
[Music]
hallelujah
see
[Music]
is loves us
so what a savior
isn't
[Music]
and bow down before
you
for he
[Music]
love is reason
god as we sing those words i just
imagine
going into the
situations that we face each week
that are challenging
situations where we're up against mental
illness
or relationships that are broken
or difficult jobs or sick children
and i just imagine
what it would be if we are
entering those spaces
asking your love to rise up
inside of us if we are
trying to embody the love of christ
filling each one of those places
god would you help us to carry that love
right now god we just open up our hearts
and we ask you to speak to us
show us the areas where we're
disconnected from your love
and help us to reconnect
jesus
god of love would you rise up in our
lives
would you rise up in this church
community
would you rise up in our schools
and our families in our jobs
would we experience you in new ways
and would we carry your love with us
be our light
be our guide
our savior
and would we be your hands and feet
in this world
we love you jesus
it's in your name we pray together
amen
you guys can be seated and as you do if
you want to turn to the people around
you and say hello
then brett will get us started with our
message
well good evening
grace and peace i'm
really really glad to be with you all
and um
yeah it's just it's good to be here and
that includes as always those join us
online we love y'all lots and
as well as anyone here who's new um
you know sometimes i think we just we
just need a a god moment we need
we need christ to speak you know because
it's it's one thing for um me to say
words or us to say prayers and
um
but it's just another for us to enter
into worship and just open up space for
the holy spirit to connect and move and
speak and
allow allow god to just do his thing so
i'm really grateful for
the worship team and just for a
community that's willing to like go
there in those ways and and be
vulnerable with god you know trust again
open up again it's beautiful
um
so we are in let's see this is um
message number two
and uh in our in our first peter part
four
series
part four yes we have gone verse by
verse through the book of first peter um
we have taken breaks so we don't we
don't necessarily just go straight to
the book um but here we are we've got uh
this week and then two more weeks after
that and then we will be uh have
completed the book of first peter
and uh i'm sure a number of you are
excited about that i'll be a little sad
but then again i am a little theological
nerd so
um
so the the uh let's see next week well
last week i should say we talked about
leadership concept of servant leadership
and serving as christ um
did
that's really where peter is kind of
applying that to the church that was
last sunday next sunday we'll be going
into some themes of anxiety and such um
but tonight
the title is the great deflation
the great deflation and um our text is
gonna be first peter chapter five versus
five through six
and um
we're gonna do something a little
different and i'm gonna actually read
two different versions of it tonight
so i want to read the first um will be
the new living it'll be a translation
the second is going to be eugene
peterson's paraphrase of the bible
called the message
um so the difference between a
translation and a paraphrase is
basically a translation is really going
for word for word accuracy
um
whereas so basically like in in this you
know the new testament's written mainly
in coin a greek so it's like the
translator's trying to say okay what's
that greek word how do i get that into
english kind of an as close to a
one-to-one as you can do which of course
is somewhat impossible you can't ever
literally do a one-to-one because every
culture language is tied to culture and
it has different shades of meaning you
know in the same way like english house
like yes in spanish it's like casa but
you know that has its own kind of
connotations of what home is in that
culture and you know so it's
it's always language is a little bit
slippery and hard to say like oh this
means that this in greek means that in
english you know it's always a little
shady but that's what a translator is
trying to do is kind of okay let me let
me connect these
whereas a pair a paraphrase is very
different a paraphrase
is basically asking what is the um the
big idea or the meaning of this sentence
in that language how do i say that in
plain english
which is why if you've ever like
struggled to really engage the bible
maybe you've tried you're like i need to
read more of the bible and you come to
it and you're like
i can't understand this i don't know
what this is saying
um i would highly suggest you grab
eugene peterson's paraphrase of the
bible the message
um
it's it's just excellent so if you're
trying to do like a bible study you need
a translation if you're trying to read
the bible and generally understand what
it's getting at paraphrase is awesome so
okay so we're gonna start with a um
translation um this is first peter
chapter five verses five through six it
says in the same way
you who are younger
must accept the authority of the elders
and all of you dress yourselves in
humility
as you relate to one another for god
opposes the proud
but gives grace to the humble that's a
quote from proverbs 3 verse 34 verse 6
so humble yourselves under the mighty
power of god and at the right time he
will lift you up in
honor
so um the greek word being translated
here as like humble and humility and
and all that is the the greek word
tapanaphrasune
that's a mouthful
yes i had to practice that this week and
um so tabinofrasune basically um
it means humiliation of mind um or
lowliness of mind and that might kind of
make it sound initially like okay so god
wants us to be humiliated
awesome
you know sort of like oh gosh um but i
think that would be a misunderstanding
and said
the the idea is really that humility is
um we might say it's it's god and his
grace and goodness kind of bringing us
back down to earth
so um for example if pride um kind of as
we talked about last week with
leadership pride for leadership it's
kind of worse it starts to kind of push
us to like lord it over others
you know to kind of
inflate our sense of self and um be try
kind of pretend to be more than we are
um
if um
well then then humility of course is the
opposite of that humility is the great
deflation you can kind of think of it
like a balloon that sort of
actually had a little funny moment
yesterday where my
son he found a deflated helium balloon
he's like hey dad watch this and he's
trying but of course it was deflated so
it had no more helium he's like this is
going to be great he's like hello hello
hello oh darn
cute cute but you can think of like a
balloon right that kind of floats up and
that's sort of like kind of what pride
is right sort of this inflation and then
humility though is the great deflation
it's sort of like you know put a hole in
that or just if it's not tied you just
kind of let it out you've all seen the
balloon kind of
you know just come in what's happening
there
um
the the balloon is returning to its
natural form
right and in the same way humility is is
kind of us returning to our natural
selves so this brings us to the
marvelous paraphrase by eugene peterson
what i love about this paraphrase is
you'll notice he never actually says the
word
humble
or
humility
instead what he does is he he just puts
the meaning of tapanaphrasune into plain
english and it's just it's really
creative and um just stunning so he he
says this first peter 5 5-6 in the
message paraphrase
and you who are younger
uh you must follow your leaders but all
of you leaders and followers alike are
to be down to earth with each other
for god has had it with the proud but he
takes delight in just plain
people
so be content with who you are don't put
on heirs
god's strong hand is on you he'll
promote you at the right time
bravo eugene peterson
what is humility humility is the grace
of you
simply being
you
we might say it's you
naked
which i realize this very awkward thing
to say
um and the church is like well this is
the lord's house well it kind of well i
mean it metaphorically but kind of
literally like in a sense of like who
are you really who are you without your
fancy clothes
right in your in your fancy
um
roles and positions and and stories
that you've kind of taken on and lived
out even though you know it's like not
really who you are but you just live it
out you know who who are you
when that mask kind of comes off
that that's what humility is all about
who are you when all that remains is
simply bear you in god like can you see
how that like just goes right to the
depths of our soul
and it's really asking the question like
who who are we and and can can you kind
of see that um the more unreal the more
inflated kind of our sense of self
then and kind of false right because
it's not that this is really who i am no
no it's like a fake persona thing we do
you know that the more inflated we are
you can see how the great deflation of a
humbling or or humility can be
experienced or felt as like a
humiliation of sorts
um and yet
sometimes
like we look back years later and we're
like
that's the best thing that ever happened
to me
you know i mean like yeah i kind of
needed that um
that humbling
um
i think a
a great example of this it felt like
well at least i came to this show during
the pandemic it's the right show at the
right time
um some of you may have found it before
then i know karen miner introduced us to
it um a wonderful show on netflix shits
creek
anyone seen this one it's so good here's
the rose family you can see a picture
wonderful
wonderful um
spelled
s-c-h-i-t-t apostrophe s
not cursing church just the name
um
and so we follow this is the the rose
family and
um the rose family they start off the
show they are i mean my goodness we
don't know exactly how rich but they
come across as like very very rich like
the one percent of the one percent you
know they know all the movers and
shakers in the united states and they're
just friends with celebrities and you
know all the things
and um
the opening scene though
is literally
them
finding out that they're bankrupt
and
getting foreclosed on and like literally
the vomiting scene is like federal
agents like boom coming into the house
just carting off furniture and they're
all i mean it's honestly it's a little
bit funny it's kind of sad a
heartbreaking two you know but i mean
it's a comedy so they play it up you
know where literally they're like you
can see they're just they're just
grasping like they're just grabbing
jewelry
clothes moira the mother she has a lot
of wigs and so she's stuffing wigs her
precious wigs into this bag and she's
like oh dave ed you know just doing her
a bit and
and it's this i mean it really it's this
picture like we just watched the great
deflation
happening in real time and so they're
forced to um take refuge in this little
back country town that they bought as a
joke i was like a birthday present for
the son david there and the black shirt
and they bought this town's joke but now
it's like their last refuge they have
nowhere else to go so they're staying in
this dodgy little motel there it is
uh and they're they're just trying to
basically go from being like somebodies
so to speak to like no bodies two just
honestly we just call them regular folks
like just regular people you know so
there they are
um
like
drinking for the first time like cheap
coffee
drinking for the first time two dollar
trader joe's wine there's a moment where
moira she does have a bit of a substance
abuse problem and she's like pouring
this and she's tasty she's like oh this
is horrific david pound me another glass
uh
there's another little moment that kind
of captures their great their great
deflation this is the um an image from
the opening of season two
and it's the son david
in some sort of fancy he always has
fancy clothes a louie like viton hoodie
cool sunglasses holding you see him
wooden pitchfork he's working alongside
the amish
and this is a great picture of the great
deflation
where they're just coming back down to
earth now the point of the show as i
take it though is not simply just to you
know poke fun at the way that
i don't know we can kind of the way
wealth and our addiction to status can
make us look foolish that would be sort
of i guess one reading of the show um
but i think at a much deeper level it's
sort of a parable
a parable about how
insecurity
and loneliness
masquerade as arrogance
but humility is content to wear no mask
at all this is really where the the show
is quite redeeming and beautiful is
because they're really like the story is
not oh these folks used to have it all
and they were so happy but now they lost
it all and so it's sad and we get to see
them be sad like yes they go through the
time of the great deflation and it is
they experience it for sure as a
humiliation
but actually by you know
even just a few seasons in they're
already starting to see like oh my gosh
we were living in
unreality
we were fake we were fakers we were we
were distant from ourselves we were
distant from one another our lives were
unraveling our family was unraveling and
we thought we had it all
but actually we had to lose it all
to find it
does that sound like anyone
in the scriptures you have to sometimes
you have to lose it all
to find it sometimes you have to give
your life away
to find it like this is the path of it's
the path of humility right so it's not
about like oh
i need to be more humble so i'm just a
nothing and a nobody i'm just a i'm just
terrible i'm just a worm in the side of
god you know like what no no it's it's
about it's the great return it's the
great deflation it's coming back to like
oh
i'm just me
and that may sound very simple but it's
actually that's a really profound and
challenging
journey
um
in other words we might say it like this
you know scratch a prideful person
and what do you find underneath not what
you might expect you might think well
i'm gonna find someone who i mean
they're just full of themselves they're
so confident
but no scratch your prideful person and
what do you find underneath all that
bluster and all that is what it's
insecurity
fear
in a similar way scratch a humble person
and what do you find again not what you
might expect
you might expect to find oh this they
just don't think anything of this oh i'm
just terrible and no no no no what do
you find
security
someone who's relaxed
because they are just themselves
themselves
you know and i think
in essence this is exactly what peter in
this passage is
naming i want to look again at some of
these wonderful turns of phrase
god takes delight in just plain
people
first five what does that mean plain
people initially it was kind of i did i
think a mystery in this initially i
thought wait boring
boring people is that gods but then i
was like no no no not not like boring or
not you know vanilla personalities or
something although god delights not
personality you know so i'm not saying
it's bad but
obviously it's not about being like just
born or something to be accepted by god
this is saying
just you being you
it's enough i've said it before like
it's funny how it's like we spend
so much of our lives just trying to
become who god always just made us to be
like you would think that'd be like the
ease well step one that's easy super
easy but man there's some just some
pressure from the world that like
it's probably that we're i'm sure
psychologist therapist could explain it
more you know where
as young children we figure out who we
need to be to be accepted by others be
loved be cool to be you know whatever
and we like play out the story of that
person you know i mean like there's
something probably to that so that so
much of our faith journey
is learning to like
drop the
show you know drop the act
and like just
be a plain
person
the key mark of christian maturity is
learning to be
exactly who god created me
you
to be
and in this sense um the journey towards
christ
is often about um we're less about as
we've said before
adding things to me
it's it's often so much more about
stripping away
taking away
things that um i've picked up but i
shouldn't have for example
letting go of the stories
that others have told about me that i
like took on
and they have come to define me
letting go of roles that don't fit me
but i did it because well i just thought
i could make so much money or i thought
that's what my dad wanted or you know
whatever we have a million reasons but
we just take on these rules letting go
of the need to please
everyone around me
any people pleasers in recovery
i am the chief of sinners i am yes
uh letting go of what others think about
me letting go of the need to project
perfection
to the world outside me
another beautiful turn of phrase from
verse 5 be down to earth with each other
what does that mean be down to earth i
think in a relational sense it basically
means
don't be pretentious with each other i
was kind of reflecting on how every
social situation
sort of invites its own form of pretense
in other words
projecting pretending to be more than i
actually am
right and that's to be pretentious um
but being down to earth is the exact
opposite so like for example social
situation i was thinking of the college
classroom i really experienced this in
graduate school
profoundly um but i'm sure it happens in
college too um
where you know people are all like
there's like a certain segment of the
class doesn't care
right okay and maybe depending on the
college in the class and whatever maybe
it's 80 but there's like a certain
segment oh they care
right they're in and it's not just that
like i'm passionate about learning it's
like no i want to be seen as the
smartest person in the room and i want
to impress that professor and so i'm
gonna shoot that hand
i have an answer i have a thought right
and it's like this weird and you get
this weird competition between like two
or three people who are all kind of vine
to be the right this what is this this
is
kind of being pretentious it's it's sort
of putting on the show of like i know it
all when really you're like they're in
the class to learn it's okay right like
you can learn things just be open and
you know have to have all the answers
right um i was thinking about um
even the way like family
family sort of on the one hand of course
families can be good and beautiful but
family like invites us to
um
well we wanna we wanna
project to the world that our family
really has it together
you know
and you just it's such a temptation to
like oh little johnny
never better little susie oh just she's
an angel you know and it's like really
our little johnny little susie always
angels you know
i realize these are cliche names i'm
just going to um
like you know like but we just we
pretend right we even have kind of the
family secrets and things you know
they're like hey uh
don't you be honest about what's going
on with this family don't you air our
dirty laundry to that counselor you know
i mean like we're just we we did the
even family kind of invites its own sort
of pretense um a neighborly conversation
simple neighborly conversation kind of
becomes about you know
projecting a certain status a certain
you know
make them make money too you know
whatever weirdness we get into
especially in the suburbs we do this all
the time
um
even i was thinking the church not the
church
of course
right kind of what's the temptation here
we
well we have certain values you know
certain beliefs and we like want to be
seen perhaps as like the bearer of the
holders and so we you know it's like we
start to we want to look spiritual too
you know we want to look holy
maybe holier than the others
right at all it's it all just plays out
what's what's peter saying though be
down to earth with each other in other
words
my goodness at least here
let's stop
can i get an amen like let's stop let's
let's just be real just be honest
and oh my what could god do with a group
of people no matter how small of just
learning to be like okay look
this is this is who i am you know i have
some strengths
and i have some really embarrassing
things about myself you know i can just
just be real because the truth is what
do we find everyone has those things
everyone has on you you think when
you're gonna be vulnerable oh everyone's
gonna abandon me
i'll be all alone standing there the
dumb one you know
and what do you find actually no
people connect
with you in that place
finally um i'll close with this he says
be content
with who
you are
not communion i'm not going to take
communion yet
but um be content with who you are
um i want to close with this there's a
short little poem i searched high and
low for this week i could not find the
full thing um
online but it was written by paul grout
who's an artist
and poet and i just remembered it from a
book i read years ago and there's like
these just a few lines that have never
left me you ever have like a thing like
that where it just it grips you and it
like stays even if you just read it like
once or twice but it just it was like i
think that's a moment of god speaking
you know and this was one of those
moments for me
and um
the just for a little background the
point what he's describing is basically
the transition to the modern era um the
last few hundred years a lot has changed
as you know the world is different like
we're just we don't live in tight-knit
communities anymore um we live inside
and we don't we aren't engaged with
nature as much we um
we can be well technology for all of
it's good you know penicillin that's a
win um
but a lot of other things it's like
meh you know
and he that's what the point is about so
just a few lines from he he says um this
this is what has been lost to us
the night sky
dancing around a fire
comfort
with our bodies
with our
faces
sharing
that loss
grieving
those lines have never left me
specifically it's the it's the one
comfort
comfort with our bodies
with our
faces
i've reflected on that a lot i wonder if
he's talking about like the power of
mirrors
i thought about that like a few hundred
years ago maybe
you like don't even have access to a
mirror maybe you have like one little
small one and it's not very good and you
can barely even see yourself you know
you try to do your hairs it's like we're
just so aware aren't we so aware and
then you fast forward now it's not just
mirrors
now it's online in the photos and lord
help us the filters
maybe at its best it's like we want to
look cute or we want to look handsome or
okay but it's like oh and it's worse it
just quickly gets into
not not good
comfort with our bodies
with our faces and i might add comfort
with our smiles
and
our crooked teeth
comfort with our laughs
with our personalities
comfort with our strengths
and
weaknesses
comfort
with our
divorces
comfort
with our business that did not
succeed
comfort with our children
gloriously beautiful
and terrible
as they are
comfort with families who cannot
understand
or accept
parts of us
comfort with our shabby home
grungy carpets and all
comfort with our skin color
education level
income
comfort with our bodies
with our faces
the church is the place
of
the great deflation
where we are all on the journey together
learning to be exactly who christ made
us to be nothing more nothing less
walking that out and authenticity and
vulnerability
that really is the heartbeat of
humility
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
as we take in the bread
the body of christ as we take in the
blood
in the
wine
may it be just a moment
where where we're able to come
uh through christ authentically maybe
for the first time you know sometimes
maybe we come in this space and we feel
that need to pretend
that need to put on heirs as peter
writes
but tonight let's just come
to christ as our selves
that's the invitation
we practice here at the table what's
called an open table meaning if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
in communion then you are welcome to do
that um instructions are on the screen
for for how we go about that
so
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
so
[Music]
one of my favorite artists growing up
was uh lauren hill and
she had this line that um has stuck with
me
um kind of like brett was saying those
lines of that point that just that thing
that always comes back to you
and it she used to say better the real
you than the fake somebody else
and
i used it as a tagline on my emails
forever just because it was a reminder
to me every time i'd go type an email
you know like authenticity mindy
be yourself
um and invite other people to be their
selves make space for people's stories
and um
i the song that we're gonna close with
tonight is called known and loved
and um what i love about
the gospel is it makes room for us
to be who we are
and for that to be a good thing because
the
verse in psalms it says you're fearfully
you're wonderfully made
and and he knows us he loves us so
there's no reason to put on the mask
there's no reason to pretend
he has seen it all
and he said it was good
so
i invite you guys to sing this song with
us
and as a statement over your own life
i'm known i'm loved i'm secure in who
god made me to be
[Music]
we've been hiding
in the shadows
and
afraid of you
we've been wandering
in the darkness
but if we only
knew
[Music]
we are known and loved
you
[Music]
we've been waiting
in this mercy
your presence is our home
[Music]
we're your children
loved forever
now every fear
is
[Music]
we are known and loved
there is no fear
anymore
cause all that's left is mercy
there is no fear
in your love
you're the god of mercy
there is no fear
anymore
cause you're the god of mercy
there is no fear
in your love
[Music]
we are
[Applause]
[Music]
loved by you
you
we are known
and loved
by you
[Music]
thanks so much
thank you so much for being here tonight
and being with us
you
being fully yourself
add something to this community it adds
something to the world that is not there
if you're not being fully yourself
fully loved and fully known
don't forget about the welcome to the
table class that's happening at the end
of the month uh you can sign up for that
a little table out there with the cards
or you can message us
if you're watching online leave a
comment or message us online for that
i'll be available in the back if you
would like prayer somebody to talk to
you or just a hug
i love hugs
and i'd also like to send you out into
your week with a reminder of who you are
at your core so if you would like you
can stand to your feet
these words i believe are true
for every single person in here
and every single person outside of these
doors
you can also hold out your hands if you
like just in a posture of receiving
you
are a child of god
are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true
on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the reminder and commitment to
extend these gifts of love and
compassion grace
and unconditional love to everybody you
come in contact with this week
be blessed
have a great week we hope to see you
back here next sunday good night
um